the worst advice for me was always
taking the safer route there's plenty of
people that would probably have better
been served taking the safer out but for
me not quitting my job that would have
been terrible advice and the same degree
when I made the decision I wanted to
sell my gyms not selling them would have
been terrible advice given who I was
then now the person that I am now
probably could have continued to scale
my location from 6 to 20 to 50 to 100
and maybe 10 years later I would have
400 locations right now and maybe I'd be
wealthier in terms of net worth I don't
know but I don't think I was the person
then that could have done that and stuck
with it I'm wealthier now because I'm
more patient